[Música]
y
teherán la capital de la república
islámica de irán fue el escenario de la
cumbre trilateral entre los presidentes
de rusia irán y turquía o turquía países
que buscan mejorar su estrategia de
influencia en la región y hacer también
contrapeso a la reciente visita del
presidente de eeuu joe biden por la
región de medio oriente pero la cumbre
en la capital iraní bajo el formato de
astaná tiene varios temas de fondo
veamos algunos de ellos no es solamente
hablar de la influencia de la región
también para hablar o hablaron de la
guerra de ucrania en donde turquía se
muestra como un país negociador también
como puente entre la otan occidente y
rusia también hablaron de las sanciones
internacionales que piensan sobre rusia
y la república islámica también otro
tema sobre la mesa la próxima incursión
militar turca contra los rebeldes kurdos
en la región del norte de siria también
hablaron de el futuro de este país
haciendo referencia a siria como un
conflicto que todavía está abierto y que
la necesidad que tiene irán de mejorar
su presencia en la región de medio
oriente sobre todo después de esa
posible alianza cercanía que puede haber
entre eeuu israel y arabia saudita
también en el marco de la guerra de
ucrania hay varios temas para destacar 1
la necesidad de moscú kiev y ankara de
discutir sobre la reanudación de las
exportaciones de grano ucraniano para
evitar que el mundo caiga en una crisis
alimentaria más profunda y por otro lado
también hablaron del suministro de gas y
petróleo iraní a europa debido a que
rusia no va a suministrar gas y petróleo
en las cantidades habituales debido a
problemas técnicos por lo menos en los
próximos días y también debido a las
sanciones internacionales no podemos
dejar de lado el suministro de armas en
este caso drones que son fabricados en
turquía que van para el ejército de
ucrania y el futuro del conflicto en el
donbass que ya rusia informó que su
estrategia militar de esta intervención
en el este de ucrania como yolanda
denominado va más allá de la región del
donbass entonces qué resultado arrojó
este encuentro estos tres países pueden
entonces conformar un eje o una especie
de alianza para mejorar su posición en
la región es el futuro que tiene
entonces sería un conflicto que está
abierto y rusia e irán también dijeron
que eeuu debe ser expulsado de este
conflicto de siria para estos tres
países mejorar su influencia en este
país de medio oriente estos y otros
temas porque es un barrio de los que
fueron tratados en esta cumbre vamos
entonces a analizarlos en esta edición
del debate de france 24 y para eso hemos
invitado a veronica a su auto ella es
consultor independiente en temas de
política internacional es especializada
en turquía ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de guadalajara en méxico y
nuestro siguiente invitado también está
en méxico un poco más al norte está en
la ciudad de tijuana frontera con eeuu
allí se conecta gilberto con de él es
profesor e investigador del colegio de
méxico a los dos a los dos les doy la
bienvenida a el programa pero les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar todas
sus preguntas y comentarios en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter
instagram y facebook donde nos
encuentran como france24 s arroba sant y
luego que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta para que dejen los comentarios
es número el debate efe 24 les recuerdo
que en youtube también pueden seguir
nuestra señal en streaming y también les
recuerdo y aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast los invito
para que los escuchen porque todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa ya están
disponibles en app el podcast de podcast
en spotify deezer hyung jin muy bien
pues damos de de una de inmediato con el
debate vamos de inmediato a la discusión
pasó entonces a saludar a veronica en la
ciudad de guadalajara verónica gracias
por estar con nosotros bienvenida al
programa punto de partida como me gusta
llamar a la primera pregunta para
conocer posiciones de los invitados en
balance y resultados su análisis de este
encuentro a tres bandas en la ciudad de
teherán cuál es su opinión
en primer lugar muchas gracias por el
espacio buenas tardes tati santiago ya
gilberto es un honor estar con ustedes
es importante destacar que este proceso
como bien mencionaste se da en el marco
del proceso de astaná que fue un proceso
iniciado por el año 2017 de alguna
manera para empezar
de alguna manera reconducir
el conflicto sirio que para ese momento
ya llevaba seis años de existencia y una
gran crisis humanitaria
en este marco se reunieron también por
un contexto muy particular como vimos
hace poco la gira de bailén por el medio
oriente con dos objetivos claros el tema
de la seguridad por una parte de la
reconfiguración de la seguridad en el
marco de estas negociaciones del chase y
aguayo plan de acción integral conjunto
las negociaciones de viena o las
negociaciones locales nucleares iraníes
que están actualmente en un punto muerto
y por otra parte de alguna manera
reconstruir sus alianzas estratégicas
con israel y con arabia saudita por otra
parte en conflicto en ucrania
trajo como consecuencia no sólo la
crisis alimentaria sino la crisis del
precio de los energéticos que será otro
de los objetivos entonces en parte esta
crisis esta reunión tripartita se
entiende alguna manera para mostrar
músculo y para de alguna manera renovar
lo que yo llamo una alianza estable no
sólida en tanto los tres países tienen
agendas divergentes en la región pero si
una alianza estable en cuanto les
podemos pensar un poco más en los
pormenores pero básicamente dos cosas el
en el marco de siria el freno por el
momento por parte de rusia irán a la
incursión turca que ya lo vamos a
mencionar
y el otro punto digamos para para
empezar la conversación también sería
el cierre de filas y la mediación turca
en particular en el en el conflicto de
ucrania para desbloquear el bolardo de
esa claro ese papel que está jugando a
turquía de ser un poco país mediador
entre otan europa unión occidente contra
rusia ya lo vamos a analizar
veronica son varios de los puntos que
tengo para analizar a lo largo del
programa le doy la palabra gilberto
punto de partida a gilberto su
perspectiva su opinión sobre los
resultados de esta cumbre en teherán lo
saludo y le doy la bienvenida allí en la
ciudad de tijuana
muchas gracias santiago un saludo
veronica también a ti
esta reunión se da efectivamente en un
contexto muy complejo para rusia pero
también para los otros dos actores lo
que ha resaltado la prensa internacional
es precisamente que es una especie de
reunión de actores débiles sin embargo
como se da en el marco de astaná no debe
verse como algo tan excepcional en
realidad
en esta reunión y la declaración
conjunta esconde una serie de
determinaciones bastante fuertes
particularmente para turquía
a pesar de que turquía lo haya manejado
como si fuera todo a favor suyo sin
embargo lo que aparece es que si le
están marcando tanto rusia como
irán
límites en cuanto a lo que le van a
permitir hacer en la frontera con
conseguiría dentro del sitio y esto me
parece que es muy importante no obstante
se da por supuesto en el contexto de la
crisis alimentaria en el contexto de la
guerra de ucrania y tiene muchísimas
muchísimas entradas en estos en estos
aspectos que seguramente habrá preguntas
acerca de los drones se olvidan
es
sumamente
importante hay muchos temas para
analizar voy a comenzar para terminar
esta overview esta vista general del de
esta reunión pasó a preguntarle a
gilberto tanto gilberto como verónica
hayan dado algunas luces de la necesidad
de estos tres países de tener que
estrechar lazos mostrarse unidos
mostrarse cercanos y amistosos entre
ellos tres pese a tener agendas muy
distintas aquí prácticamente cada uno
está yendo por el lado que más le
conviene en ciertos puntos y en ciertos
temas pero cuál es la necesidad de
turquía irán y rusia de mostrarse
sólidos gilberto
tiene que ver con los intereses de cada
uno de ellos para ser ya está en el
centro de la relación entre estos tres
países como ya se ha mencionado
y para turquía particularmente es
fundamental siria turquía le apostó todo
al conflicto dentro desidia le había
apostado todo a sacar al presidente
bashar al-assad sin embargo cuando esto
no se conformó confirmó tenía 34
millones de sirios refugiados dentro de
su país y además el conflicto con los
kurdos este este asunto de los kurdos
para turquía es realmente la piedra en
esa
hacia los kurdos los ve como aliados
guiados estadounidenses sin embargo los
kurdos tienen una gran flexibilidad en
cuanto a alianzas soy sin fallar la
alianza con eeuu y se ven obligados a
aliarse con el régimen sirio
de ponerle un alto a turquía este en
cambio para irán la importancia pues es
mucha porque justamente rusia fue la que
boicoteó la
el regreso del tratado nuclear del
acuerdo nuclear con eeuu rusia
prácticamente lo boicoteó cuando
empezaba el conflicto en ucrania por
temor de que irán se rompiera la
solidaridad con rusia en cuanto a
energéticos y empezar a venderle gas y
petróleo a europa claro que no hay que
olvidar que irán no solamente es un
fundador de la opep no solamente es un
gran productor de petróleo sino que
tiene muchísimo ac es el segundo país
con los mayores yacimientos de gas
natural en el mundo claro después de
rusia claro tiene una importante franja
en la costa del mar caspio en donde
tiene grandes pozos grandes zonas de
extracción de gas muy importante por eso
entra en la ecuación de la crisis
energética de europa que ahí puede tener
discrepancias con rusia también ya lo
vamos a analizar no se me adelanté
gilberto quiero entonces que hablemos
decir ya que fue el punto central de
este encuentro fue el tal vez el más
extenso esto países están decididos a
reestructurar allí su presencia a
mejorar la presencia que tienen en síria
le pregunto a veronica en qué estado se
encuentra este conflicto los medios de
comunicación hemos ya cometido el error
de haber abandonado un poco el tema
decidiría poco seguimiento lo hemos
estado haciendo en los últimos meses
porque pues tal vez no hay hechos
dramáticos para contarle a los
televidentes y por eso lo vamos dejando
de lado porque ucrania lo ha empañado
pero el conflicto en siria sigue abierto
este país no ha firmado un acuerdo de
paz no hay una pacificación el conflicto
sigue allí latente cómo está la
situación allí y como estos países
pueden mejorar su
presencia allí sacando a eeuu como han
dicho a ellos
en primer lugar me permito también
una línea argumental que había iniciado
gilberto que me parece importantísima y
que nos permite entender hoy el
conflicto sirio que es el norte de siria
claro actualmente el gobierno sirio
controla en torno a dos tercios del
territorio
rusia e irán en este conflicto está en
una posición
digamos de rivalidad con con turquía
turquía y está actualmente luego de tres
incursiones la primera en el 2017
básicamente partió el norte de siria al
oeste el éufrates la segunda fue una
incursión en áfrica que es una región
poblada mayoritariamente por kurdos la
tercera que es buscó o busca uno de los
objetivos que es generar una zona de
amortiguación entre turquía digamos en
la frontera siria donde turquía tenía la
intención de reubicar en torno a 2
millones
de refugiados sirios a esto rusia e irán
se oponen terminantemente y así quedó
declarado en justamente en la
declaración de este gran dos puntos
fundamentales analizar el primero la
manifestación en contra de cualquier
tipo de incursión turca por tanto esa
idea de la zona de amortiguación
quedaría descartada y la segunda cuando
hablan del retorno de los refugiados
dice no sólo que va tiene que ser
voluntario y negociado sino que tienen
que regresar a su lugar de origen esto
es un punto fundamental porque uno de
los objetivos iniciales de turquía
también era reconfigurar de alguna
manera demográficamente el norte de
siria sur y si lo analizamos bajo la
lente que plantea muy bien gilberto de
alguna manera la zona kurda también es
un elemento de control que juega en
favor de siria y de irán en contra de
turquía verdad la verdad ha sido ha sido
en el pasado por tanto aquí hay un
interés divergente fundamental
y en cuanto a rusia me permito también
ampliar un poco la lente del conflicto
e incluir pues la la cooperación que ha
habido extraoficial si se quiere entre
rusia israel en tanto israel ha
realizado incursiones en el oeste de
siria con
digamos la la venia de rusia hoy sabemos
que el espacio aéreo sirio está
controlado por rusia sur y este es otro
elemento de tensión con irán y por
último otro elemento es el paulatino
regreso de asad al mundo árabe por
decirlo de alguna manera ya ha habido
contactos con jordania ha habido una
visita a emiratos a un acercamiento
también de tercera línea con arabia
saudita con el líbano con egipto y esto
es algo que ciertamente rusia ve con
buenos socios y para terminar breve creo
por favor cuando uno habla de
geopolítica no debe olvidar que hoy en
siria una de cada dos personas está
fuera de su casa
si el éxodo de los sirios es gigantesco
la mayoría de ellos hacia otros países
del mundo árabe y muchos de ellos hacia
europa hay que decir que en este
rompecabezas rusia e irán están del lado
del presidente bachar al asad de hecho
rusia tiene una base militar muy
importante en el norte de siria en la
región en la ciudad de latakia en la
costa siria sobre el mediterráneo pero
turquía apoya a los rebeldes que están
en contra del presidente al asad
entonces ahí es donde estas estos tres
países chocan bueno y en otros múltiples
escenarios como ya los ha explicado
veronica sobre todo por las posiciones
militares en el norte gilberto el punto
importante para analizar del tema de
siria es el futuro que tiene este país
se puede encontrar una salida a este
conflicto aquí eeuu puede volver a
entrar a tener una posición de choque y
despierto otra vez ya vive el conflicto
que futuro político puede tener allí y
vuelve a chocar ankara con washington en
este escenario y con la unión europea
por supuesto
para eeuu en algún momento lo esencial
fue combatir
isis y encontraron que los kurdos serán
la fuerza principal en la que se podían
apoyar para derrotar a crisis
fue justamente por medio de esta alianza
que se hizo retroceder a esa
organización terrorista abiertamente y
no es tan fácil para eeuu
abandonar completamente a estos aliados
que los apoyaron en ese en ese combate
sin embargo eeuu todo parece indicar que
está tratando de alejarse tomar
distancia este respecto de la región no
lo puede ser completamente sigue siendo
una región muy importante tanto para la
economía mundial como estratégicamente
sin embargo quisiera economizar eeuu de
eso y sin embargo hay aquí hay una
digamos un nudo gordiano que no pueden
desatar tan fácilmente tratan de
alejarse cuando el trump decidió retirar
sus tropas de siria al poco tiempo
regresó regreso diciendo que era por el
petróleo etcétera sin embargo la
situación es complicada el viaje
reciente de vaivén del presidente vaivén
a la región también habla de esta de
esta situación de esta extenso por
lograr que israel y los países árabes
colaboren y colaboren incluso en
términos militares
tiene que ver con esta retirada de eeuu
que buscan quienes
tienen esa clase vacío que no se anuncia
que no sea irán entonces la situación es
bastante compleja y para eeuu no es tan
fácil
pero bueno los cursos los cursos para
buscar de cualquier forma defender sus
posiciones y no quieren abandonar todos
los logros que han conquistado en estos
en estos 10 años bueno ya lo ven ustedes
ojo entonces a lo que pueda suceder en
síria en los próximos días o semanas
avanzó con otro tema de la agenda de
este encuentro y es la posición de
influencia de estos países en la región
ya lo decíamos en la introducción del
programa el presidente yo baiden visitó
israel y arabia saudita tratando de
mejorar la presencia de eeuu allí
tratando de acercar a riad con israel
como ya lo ha hecho con marruecos con
los emiratos árabes con otros países de
la región con bahrein también tratando
de formar una especie de bloque contra
el avance que pueda tener irán que
veronica que tan bien posicionado está
irán en la región de medio oriente tiene
algo de influencia con hezbollah en el
líbano una buena presencia en el vecino
irak donde también está eeuu todavía en
cierta forma pero que tanto pueden
temerle un avance iraní en la región o
es por el tema nuclear
creo que es una combinación de todos
esos elementos es decir hoy por hoy
podríamos vislumbrar
dos o tres bloques que a su vez son muy
si se quiere elásticos y muy endebles el
iraní se quiere es el más fuerte que
incluiría pues sería por supuesto
hezbollah los hutis en yemen irak pues
ahorita ahora en estos momentos está
tomando pues ya pues una posición con
divergencias internas pero sigue siendo
pues un espacio de influencia para para
irán
por otra parte tenemos un bloque que se
ha deformado pero que en el inicio del
conflicto era muy potente que estaba
formado por turquía qatar y este término
y la hermandad de los hermanos
musulmanes en particular en egipto
previó así si este bloque claramente se
fué desconfigurado por un lado con el
acercamiento de qatar nuevamente a los
países del golfo y por otro lado el
acercamiento también de turquía hacia
israel nuevamente la el acercamiento
fundamental con arabia saudita cerrando
el ciclo negativo tras el asesinato es
caiozzi suite y entonces e israel por
otra parte él está surgiendo este nuevo
espacio como tú dijiste una una especie
arquitectura de seguridad en torno a los
acuerdos de abra como si les han llamado
aunque con sus limitaciones también en
tanto aún en arabia saudita no forma
parte suite
la duda o el planteo a futuro es si el
mundo árabe en sí mismo podrá de alguna
manera generar o colaborar a cubrir este
vacío de poder que menciono gilberto en
particular muchas muchas
expectativas están cifradas en el foro
del néguev y en particular en la
relación arabia saudita egipto pero esto
pues por el momento son declaraciones
que
hay que ver como cómo funciona esto en
el futuro pero sin duda claro y termino
brevemente con dos elementos que tienen
que ver también con lo energético que es
ahora habremos visto el envío de drones
al
campo de gas en cariz en el
mediterráneo' que tesis realista en la
frontera entre el líbano a israel y los
ataques a plantas desalinizadoras de
agua en el mar rojo estos son dos puntos
íntimamente relacionados con la
seguridad regional claro seguridad
regional es el punto clave en esta
alianza en su opinión gilberto muy
puntual ya vamos llegando a la mitad del
programa
algo más a la pregunta y es el tema
energético usted ya mencionaba los
campos de gas que tiene irán la
importancia que tiene en su producción
de petróleo lo beneficioso que puede ser
para europa recibir gas y petróleo iraní
y sobre todo en los meses de invierno
que se avecinan aquí no genera estos
discrepancias entre teherán y moscú
además que hay otro pequeño actor en la
región que no podemos dejar de lado y es
azerbaiyán con quien ya tuvieron
acercamiento vimos a un solo fondear
legend en bakú con este gobierno muy
controvertido también por el tema de
derechos humanos pero allí estuvieron
comprando gas y petróleo
por supuesto que para europa va a ser
clave empezó a europa
y bajo presión estadounidense dada la
invasión rusa de ucrania empezó
amenazando con realizar un boicot a la
compra de energéticos particularmente
gas y petróleo de rusia y rusia contestó
diciendo nosotros somos los que vamos a
cortar el suministro
como sería un auto boicots de qué parte
la cosa que es que por supuesto les
convendría le convendría a los países
europeos
obtener gas iraní para hacer esto sin
embargo acaban de firmar rusia e irán un
acuerdo por
una carta intención por un proyectos
para proyectos por un valor aproximado
de 40 mil millones de dólares para
proyectos energéticos
entonces es probable que incluso rusia
le esté abriendo
posibilidades a irán de exportar gas y
petróleo a europa
pero sin mermar la relación que existe
entre las dos partes se parecerá un
juego bastante extraño sin embargo los
datos que están ahí más allá de las
declaraciones o de opiniones que pueden
ser un poco rápidas
me parece que
los datos nos están hablando de una
alianza más fuerte a pesar de que irán
pudiera vender gas y petróleo a europa
es decir aparentemente
afectando los intereses de rusia pero en
el fondo quizá no tanto me muevo ya
hacia el bloque final del programa la
última parte de este análisis y
obligatoriamente tengo que hablar del
tema de ucrania es el conflicto activo
de importancia en este momento de la
coyuntura internacional veronica y se
habló entre otros temas y el más
importante a nivel internacional la
posibilidad de desbloquear esa
exportación de granos y cereales
ucranianos que están allí represados
porque los puertos ucranianos están
tomados la gran mayoría de ellos por las
tropas rusas el puerto de odessa está
siendo atacado y por eso no ha sido
tomado por completo pero no está activo
para poder sacar este esta producción
que debería salir a lo largo del verano
desde ucrania aquí entendamos entonces
el papel de turquía en todo esto otra
vez mediador entre kiev y moscú
qué tan interesado estaría de liberar
esta producción de granos sabiendo que
prácticamente tiene al mundo entero de
rodillas pidiéndole que suelte
los cereales y los granos porque estamos
al borde de una hambruna a nivel mundial
y moscú tiene la sartén por el mango
como se dice
tristemente estamos en
nos estamos moviendo en un terreno donde
ya no se trata de lo correcto sino de lo
conveniente para estos estados y yo creo
que rusia está
aceptando la mediación turca para
desbloquear el puerto de odessa y por
tanto habilitar la salida de granos a
cambio dicen algunos algunos fuentes a
su vez de levantar las sanciones sobre
los granos rusos sí recordó recordemos
como tú bien mencionaste que rusia está
bajo sanciones entonces es parte
integral de esa apertura de odessa sería
también permitir la comercialización de
los granos rusos y por otra parte
también
levantar las sanciones sobre los
fertilizantes recordemos también que
rusia son euros principales exportadores
a nivel global suerte fertilizantes y se
acaba de cerrar así que creo que dos
tres semanas un acuerdo
visionario o mejor dicho milmillonario
con brasil para recibir fertilizantes
rusos por último también un dato que
creo que es interesante entender
el rol de turquía
históricamente
y muy brevemente
la mayor amenaza geopolítica de turquía
ha sido rusia ha venido del este desde
el imperio otomano recordemos que tanto
el cáucaso como ucrania o de esa
gripe a
pertenecieron al imperio otomano
entonces también hay una hay una gran
tradición que también se potencia por el
hecho de que turquía es la única salida
a aguas cálidas que tiene rusia
por tanto esto también el esfuerzo
mediador de turquía que obviamente
también juega
digamos este doble juego aprovechando
las inconsistencias de la unión europea
eeuu también es reposicionarse como como
el actor que tiene la llave del flujo de
los granos verdad a través del bósforo
claro y la puerta de rusia y de ucrania
al mundo porque son las costas que rusia
y ucrania tienen para poder acceder a
los diferentes mercados del mundo
recordemos que el puerto el báltico
funciona solamente en algunos momentos
del año cuando el hielo lo permite y
pues la costa del norte de rusia
permanece congelada buena parte del año
y es prácticamente el acceso que tiene
el mundo occidental por el mediterráneo
en gilberto importante para entender acá
este análisis para ir cerrando que ya
vamos llegando a la parte final del
programa la otan y occidente
completamente en silencio ante este
encuentro no han dicho nada ni en
washington ni en bruselas ni
ningún país de la unión europea qué pasa
gilberto
me parece que públicamente no digan nada
y
particularmente por lo que ya decía la
verónica hora de la cuestión de los
granos y está estos acuerdos que los que
sean lo han logrado que finalmente
totalmente negativos para para ucrania
aunque claro que tienen candados por
supuesto que que rusia no ha permitir
que salgan buques
garcía con granos con el riesgo de que
pudiera entrar armas a ucrania por esa
por esa vía sin embargo
también
por supuesto que
está esta cuestión supuesto que los
agentes diplomáticos de la otan si están
muy interesados en esto y están
discutiendo en probablemente al
menos muy puros turquía turquía a hablar
de la amenaza de vetar el ingreso de
finlandia y suecia a la organización
cosa que seguramente no nos agrada mucho
ni en washington
el análisis europeas
y la otan es por supuesto el el enemigo
declarado de rusia y rusia está inició
esta guerra en ucrania entre otras cosas
para tratar de seguir abierto
y en este encuentro el presidente iraní
dijo que la otan era una organización
sumamente peligrosa de voz interrumpirlo
para agilizar porque ya se me está
acabando el tiempo y debo preguntarle a
veronica sobre el presidente putin el
presidente de rusia y esta idea que
tiene de un nuevo orden mundial es uno
de los argumentos que han dado para
justificar esa como llaman ellos una
operación especial militar en ucrania y
es precisamente forzar
a cambiar un poco el orden internacional
en donde eeuu no es el país que ejerce
gran presión o ejerce influencia a nivel
internacional está putin consiguiéndolo
este tipo de encuentros esta cercanía
con irán con turquía el tema de los
cereales a abrirse otra vez campo de
influencia en siria como lo ve usted
yo creo que por el momento estamos
estamos en un periodo de transición
creo que putin algo que ha hecho bien a
lo largo de este tiempo ha sido pues
exponer en términos simples sin
necesidad luego de
demostrar su sostenibilidad en el tiempo
el hecho de que el mundo está cambiando
al menos en la superficie se percibe os
da la sensación de que esto es así
aunque por el momento sinceramente
estamos en un punto de transición
claramente se ha demostrado la
contracara de la interdependencia por
una parte un retroceso de los procesos
de globalización por otra y
agendas o geopolíticas que giran cada
vez más en torno al equilibrio de poder
y alianzas circunstanciales basados en
temas de agenda
desde un conflicto contenido como puede
ser el de siria con desborda regional
hasta la crisis alimentaria hasta los
energéticos soy y en particular el
surgimiento de china yo creo que él
básicamente el enfoque biberón va a ser
antes de las conclusiones rápidamente
por favor muy puntual para los 2
gilberto verónica última pregunta
ucrania se puede convertir en otra seria
un conflicto que ya lleva más de una
década y no ha terminado gilberto
rápidamente
desgraciadamente parece que esa es la
tendencia que ucrania se convierta
precisamente en un conflicto que no
termina que un conflicto en el que quien
paga los platos rotos es la población la
población civil que está sufriendo
constantemente que tiene que salir del
país que tiene que desplazarse dentro
del país y beligerante es continua
veronica su opinión otro conflicto que
se puede prolongar en el tiempo
coincido con gilberto es decir va a
haber una frontera móvil al interior de
ucrania
y es un conflicto que va a llevar tiempo
resolver me queda un minuto 30 para
concluir el programa a gilberto verónica
rápidamente sus conclusiones que vamos a
ver en las próximas semanas una
respuesta de occidente una respuesta de
eeuu esa alianza tras todos los tres
países funcionando y empezando a dar
resultados y una respuesta también de
otros países del mundo árabe como ven
ustedes que se puedan mover la
geopolítica en los próximos días
comienzo con veronica para hacer la
ronda a la inversa bueno es una pregunta
sumamente compleja pero yo diría que por
lo pronto en los procesos que ya están
en marcha van a continuar en este
sentido la reunión entera no va a
implicar un cambio sustancial la
preocupación fundamental va a estar en
torno a
liberar de esa y ya esto es son
aparentemente es es algo que está casi
resuelto y continuar la relación de eeuu
con sus aliados para bajar el precio de
los energéticos
gilberto para el cierre su conclusión
sin duda va a seguir apoyando a eeuu y
la otan con todo al gobierno de
excelencia esto va a haber esta va a ser
la respuesta principal creo yo a esta a
esta reunión sin embargo algo saca
estado perdón rusia de esto que son
drones iraníes que le van a ser de suma
utilidad en su en el conflicto ucraniano
y también sacan direcciones de irán
acerca de cómo hacerle frente a un
régimen de sanciones que va a ser muy
rudo también un sistema monetario
alternativo al de swift un sistema
bancario internacional alternativo para
quienes se salgan de la órbita
estadounidense lo cual le puede ser de
grande pues a gilberto y a veronica allí
en la república mexicana les agradezco
por haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 recuerden que
ustedes también pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales de france 24 y
también aprovecho para despedirme de
todas las personas que nos están
escuchando a través de nuestro podcast
sigan con la programación de france 24
gracias por la sintonía
[Música]